how does one save a marriage when it
seems that there is no longer attraction
both physically and intellectually
there are kids involved which is the
main reason for wanting to save the
marriage huh well all right I know a
couple of things about that I mean the
first thing I would say is that if you
haven't had any intimate interaction
with one another for quite a long period
of time that can put both people into a
stagnant state where desire starts to
slip away what what sex therapists
recommend under such conditions is to
well essentially start in some ways
start dating again so you could ask your
partner to go out to a movie or
something like that and you know maybe
when you come home you could you could
neck for a little while like teenagers
that's probably a word that no one uses
anymore but kind of pull back and you
gotta agree say not to engage in full
sexual activity for a while but to tease
each other and to play a bit even if
you're not attracted you have to act act
it out for a while and hopefully you can
get the motor running again the other
thing I would say is that you guys might
want to sit down and make a joint plan
it's like what because a marriage is
like a story that two people are acting
out simultaneously and you have to have
shared goals and because you're both
rowing the same boat let's say and if
you don't have a destination in mind
then well maybe your rowing in circles
or maybe you're just standing still so I
would say work hard to put some romance
back in the relationship you know you
could say to each other look let's try
this for six months and just see how it
goes we'll have two dates a week for the
first month we won't have any sex but
we'll play around and then you know
we'll see how that goes and and but
we'll try it out for them for the whole
for the whole six months there are
reasons to save a marriage I mean it's
hard on kids divorce is really hard on
kids and it's hard on the adults
involved too so what I would say
you have to negotiate an agreement and
you you know you could try the future
authoring program both of you what I
would recommend for example is that you
each do the future authoring program
separately so that's at self authoring
com because then you both have a life
plan and then you could sit down and
read each other's future authoring plans
and see if you have some things in
common and then see if you can figure
out how to support each other with
regards to each of you obtaining what
you want